[Music]
the best movie on Amazon Prime right now
is Interstellar this movie does
everything right the acting the
storytelling the score and the
cinematography everything is basically
perfect my personal opinion for the best
movie on Hulu is Edge of Tomorrow
starring Tom Cruz and Emily Blunt so
basically this movie is Groundhog Day
but with aliens and a lot more
explosions the best movie on Max we have
the Batman starring Robert Patton AKA
Batson for the best movie by a very
small margin is Spirited a Christmas
movie starring Will frell and Ryan
Reynolds the best movie on Netflix is
Dune definitely one of my favorite
movies of all time and it has Timothy
Shalom so you can't go
wrong and for Disney Plus's best movie
we have Ratatouille Pixar's magnum opus
their best work of all time